the media play propagandists for Hamas
Seattle passes the Amazon tax and the
Trump administration cracks down on
leakers I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show
oh man so much news to get to you today
but first I want to let you know the Ben
Shapiro show you missed it we're headed
to a live venue this August I'm
recording my podcast live in Dallas and
Phoenix and you'll be able to see me in
person and join in an audience Q&A and
we'll also be doing a special VIP event
beforehand with in signing a
meet-and-greet for 200 superfans so
visit daily wire.com slash events for
more information presale tickets
actually are on sale today at 10 a.m.
local time so if you're a daily wired
premium subscriber he had access to
seats until May 17th at 10:00 p.m. and
that's when general admission go on sale
and tickets will run out fast if you're
not a subscriber this is indeed the best
time to subscribe so you can get one of
these tickets in advance again visit
dailyrx.com slash events for more info
that's daily wired.com slash events for
more info in August Dallas and Phoenix
be there be square daily wear comm slash
events and subscribes you can get those
early tickets and we can meet we can
hang out it'll be we'll be best friends
it'll just be awesome
now as I say there's lots of news
there's lots of news breaking but before
I get to any of that news first I want
to say thank you to our sponsors over at
zip recruiter so your business needs
better employees how do I know because
you are a business and all businesses
need better employees well if you're
seeking to upgrade your existing
employee base or if you're just looking
for a new hire zip recruiter is the
place for you they learn what you're
looking for the identify people with the
right experience and they invite them to
apply to your job these invitations have
actually revolutionized how you can find
your next tire in fact 80% of employers
who post a job on zip recruiter get a
quality candidate through the site in
just one day and zip recruiter doesn't
stop there they even spotlight the
strongest applications you receive so
you never miss a great match we use zip
recruiter here at the daily wire when
we're looking for new folks or when
we're looking to get rid of particular
producers don't sleep too easy guys the
right candidates are out there zip
recruiter is how you find them and right
now my listeners can try zip recruiter
for free just go to zip recruiters comm
slash daily wire that zip recruiter comm
slash daily wire zip recruiter comm
slash daily wire use that daily wire so
they know we sent you zip recruiter is
the smartest way to hire make sure that
you go and check them out and again use
that slash daily wire so you can try
them for free the best way to find your
new employee zip recruiter comm slash
daily wire all right so the media are
awful they're awful
I've been highly critical of the phrase
fake news because I feel like it's
overused I think there a lot of people
out there who use the phrase fake news
to mean news I don't like but what we
have seen over the past 48 hours
has been absolutely fake news from the
mainstream media who are just parroting
lines from Hamas at this point they are
just parroting lines from one of the
world's worst terror groups it is
obvious and it is disgusting really
horrify me it's nothing new in 2014 I
was on CNN in the middle of the Gaza war
and I actually told the CNN anchor to
her face that Hamas was in fact a
propaganda wing of what that CNN was a
propaganda wing of Hamas because it was
clear at that time when they were
claiming that Israel is indiscriminately
targeting civilians even as Hamas was
hiding its headquarters under a hospital
and hiding weapons in mosques and
schools see Hamas says this here it has
a certain goal their goal is to make
headlines they know they're never gonna
be able to defeat Israel in any military
fashion and they also know that Israel
has no interest in going into the Gaza
Strip again and deposing them because
then Israel has to run the place and
they don't want to do that so Hamas has
it kind of easy all they have to do is
make sure their own population doesn't
rebel against them and the way to do
that is by attacking if Israel every so
often and getting a lot of glowing press
from the world and the world is happy to
give that glowing press because the
world despises Israel for the same
reason that the world despises America
they say Israel as a colonizing power in
the Middle East even though the history
of Israel shows that the Jews have been
there continuously for three thousand
years no according to the left Israel is
a colonial imperialist power in the
Middle East
stomping its boot all over the faces of
the people who are there before that is
historically inaccurate but that is the
story that is told by folks on the left
wing and so anytime they can say that
Israel is acting illegitimate Lee they
will do that and that's exactly what
they have been doing over the past 48
hours so first I want to start with this
headline from the New York Daily News so
the New York Daily News this is 15 the
New York Daily News put up put out this
headline this was their front page today
this is a blood libel and for people who
don't know what the blood libel is a
blood libel is the old anti-semitic
canard that Jews killed Christian
children then used their blood in
Passover matzos it was used as a as a an
excuse to murder Jews and pogroms for
legitimately centuries and that's what
this is right here this daily news cover
because the idea here is that the Jews
are just happy to kill non-jews that's
the idea so here's what it says it's a
picture of Anka Trump looking very
pretty she was there at the dedication
of the new US Embassy in Jerusalem she's
dressed to the nines and the picture is
her gesturing to her to her left okay
and what she was actually gesturing to
was a
placard that is on the building that
says dedicated by US President Donald
Trump okay but the Daily News has put a
picture over that and the picture they
put over that is a picture of some
wounded Palestinian being dragged away
by other Palestinians and then in giant
headline it says daddy's little ghoul
daddy's little ghoul so to Vanka Trump's
fault
and then Hamas has now put up thousands
of people to storm the Israeli border in
an attempt to get people killed
specifically so the media will cover it
this way so it says daddy's little ghoul
fifty five slaughtered in Gaza but
Ivanka all smiles at Jerusalem embassy
unveil fu Daily News fu I mean this is a
blood libel it is it's it's it's saying
Ivanka Trump was Jewish Ivanka just like
all those other Jews look at her she
doesn't care if Palestinians get killed
she doesn't care of innocents are having
their bloodshed she doesn't care about
any of those things and that's what's
happening if you look at the media
coverage today it is all that it's all
look at these innocent Palestinians
being slaughtered wholesale by the udin
it's just terrible how could the Jews do
something quite so awful now you're
getting this routine from Stephen
Colbert rights here's Stephen Colbert
mocking Donald and Ivanka and Jared
Kushner also Jewish over the Jerusalem
embassy opening now the president
couldn't be there himself because you
know the angry people so instead he sent
peace treaty Barbie and collusion Ken
[Applause]
jared explained that the embassy was
good for peace okay well isn't that
funny because he's got that they're
making fun of his high voice by piping
in somebody with a higher voice oh it's
so funny the entire media yesterday he
was putting this stuff on split-screen
they were putting on split-screen the
situation in Jerusalem with the
situation in Gaza now let's be real
about the situation in Gaza Hamas has
organized for weeks these riots at the
border in an attempt dramatically to
create footage that they can then use as
an excuse to claim that Israel is the
great oppressor in the Middle East it is
it is produced it is created this is not
a spontaneous uprising it's not a
spontaneous peaceful protest this is in
fact a series of riots directed at
invading the Israeli border and this
isn't just me saying this ok this is top
members of Hamas Hamas is the
government's in the Gaza Strip notice
yet notice that yesterday
amidst all of this chaos on the Gaza
Strip there was nothing happening in the
engine and Samaria in the West Bank
nothing Palestinian Authority they
weren't doing this so there was nobody
to border nothing was happening in
Jordan nothing was happening in Egypt
nothing was happening in Saudi Arabia
nothing was happening in Iran nothing
was happening in Syria nothing was
happening in Lebanon nothing was
happening which suggests that maybe this
was being produced for the cameras by
Hamas how do I know that it was being
produced by the cameras for the cameras
back from us well because the
Palestinians been saying this because
Hamas has been saying this so for
example let me show you let me play for
you a video of Hamas leader Yahya sin
whare okay this is from early April is
April 6th okay I'm on translate I have
the translation in front of me from
memory ok here is Yahya seonhwa who is
the head of Hamas in the Gaza Strip he's
the governor he's the guys the head of
the government there says we have come
out today and we will come out also in
the next few days our people and our
boys will surprise the entire world with
what they have in store let them wait
for our big push we will take down the
border with Israel and we will tear out
their hearts from their bodies peaceful
protest guys it's just a peaceful
protest and if you point out the
Colossus a violent terrorist group and
then the people of the Gaza Strip
elected
in 2006 to lead them this is in politic
you can't mention this this is a bunch
of women and children and babies who are
sitting peacefully and then the Israelis
started shooting them if you pay
attention to the mainstream media
coverage by the way it's not just the is
Anwar this was yesterday a Hamas
official on al-jazeera explaining that
those were not peaceful protests these
are not peaceful protesters from
al-jazeera network a senior Hamas
official named Mahmoud all Zohar again
I'll read you the translation when you
have weapons that are being wielded by
man who are able to prevent the
strongest army in the region from
entering the Gaza Strip for 51 days and
we're able to capture or kill soldiers
in that army is this really peaceful
resistance this is not peaceful
resistance missings
here's the option of armed struggle
diminished is it again a from official
no on the contrary it is growing and
developing that's clear so when we talk
about peaceful resistance we are
deceiving the public this is peaceful
resistance bolstered by a military force
and by security agencies and enjoying
tremendous popular support
it's a Hamas is very obvious about what
they're doing folks they're not hiding
the ball here the media are actively
complicit in this anti-israel blood
libel in this anti-jewish blood libel
and they are actively complicit at this
point in what amounts to a blood libel
against Jews suggesting the Jews are
indiscriminately shooting people on mass
it is a lie it is not true hey here's
tape of Palestinians attempting to
breach the border fence Israel has been
dropping leaflets all over Gaza saying
do not try to approach the border fence
or you will be shot that's because
they've been using the border fence
trying to break through the border fence
in order to kill Jews yesterday they
were saying openly there are
Palestinians who are telling the press
openly what their goal was it was so
funny the press was trying to say well
you guys don't really mean any of this
stuff right you don't really mean any of
this stuff on NPR one of the NPR anchors
a stay Gaza and with a kite with a
swastika on it why he was flying us kite
with a swastika on it and he said the
Jews go crazy when you mention Hitler so
Steve Inskeep was the anchor he said he
asked if he knows the Israelis are using
the swastikas to discredit Gazans right
so the so NPR trying to change the story
into
well you know they're selectively
choosing your type with the swastika you
know that's that's what they're doing
here so what is the Gaza and say says
it's what we mean we want them to burn
they're not being subtle there's no
subtlety here
hey the Gaza Strip is filled with people
who want Israel destroyed and want to
kill Jews okay and those people have
elected people in the Hamas government
in order to do just that if they don't
like what's going on in the Gaza Strip
well they're supposedly supposed to have
elections now there are a lot of people
who are peace-loving I'm sure in the
Gaza Strip
but not the people who are approaching
the border yesterday those are not
people who are interested in peace and
they're certainly interested in being
used as human shields by Hamas there is
no question that this is what Hamas is
doing they've admitted this hey you can
see that these guys are bringing
sandbags toward the border wall and now
you see this guy this kid they're
sending out kids and teenagers to bring
tires to the border wall and then burn
the tires as a distraction is a
smokescreen and then you can see all
these guys hiding behind the hill
they've been trying to go up to the
border fence with bolt cutters and
trying to cut through the border fence
this is one of the things they've been
doing also Israel had experienced
yesterday a serious problem okay does
this look like peaceful protest to you
it's not peaceful prozis a giant clouds
of black smoke that are coming from tyre
fires that are being used to obscure the
terrorist activities of people along the
border
hey the IDF the Israeli Defense Forces
they tweeted out and they tweeted out
tape of yesterday of shooting attack on
Israeli forces you're told that Israel
was firing on unarmed people
the IDF tweeted out yesterday afternoon
the IDF received intelligence the Kumasi
operatives were preparing to cross
through the security fence from northern
Gaza IDF Special Forces arrived at the
scene and eight armed terrorists hurled
pipe bombs and grenades at the soldiers
and the security fence and they've made
the tape available for anyone to look at
online but we're being told by the media
that Israel is the real problem here
Israel obviously is the serious issue
okay all of this is just nonsense it's
just nonsense and I have more evidence
that it's nonsense in just one second
first I want to say thanks to new
sponsors okay our new sponsors are the
folks over at betterment so I'm a person
who has a financial advisor I have a
financial advisor because I'm not the
person who wants to sit there and check
through my investments and try to figure
out what's a good investment what's a
bad investment also just like anyone
else I have a tendency to overreact to
market conditions well this is why you
need a professional investment advisor
who is going to make sure that your best
interests are taken into account
betterment is the largest online
financial adviser designed to help
customers build wealth plan for
retirement achieve their financial goals
and it's not gonna cost you an arm and
leg to have a financial adviser now they
have low fees hidden costs are nowhere
to be found at betterment no matter who
you are or how much money you invest
you've got everything from one low
transparent management fee so they're
not making money off of you you know
trading in a bunch of stock instead
you're paying one low transparent
management fee the advice is in your
best interest they are your fiduciary
which means they make recommendations in
your best interest they're not
incentivized to sell certain funds
they're not trying to sell you on
anything this isn't one of those boiler
room movies these are folks who are
there to advise you on the best
investments to make and they don't make
money off of selling all of these
recommended funds then they have tools
to help you understand how you're doing
as well they offer personalized advice a
suite of tools to help you know whether
you're on track take your investing
goals or get the retirement you want and
when you need it their tools and
guidance can help you get on track
now listen investing involves risk but
one of the ways to help mitigate that
risk is by working with an investment
advisor and the folks over at betterment
do a really great job the Ben Shapiro
show listeners right near can get up to
we can get up to one year of Managed of
management for free up to one year of
management for free for more information
visit betterment comm slash Shapiro
that's betterment comm slash Shapiro
again betterment comm slash capiro
there's a reason that you should be
looking at betterment there's a reason
you should have a financial advisor I
have one you should have one too
betterment comm slash capiro and you can
get up to one year managed for free
so again betterment comm slash apparel
use that slash appear up so they know
that we sent you ok so again all of the
evidence is that Hamas is using human
shields that Hamas is attempting to
create headlines and they're doing just
that they're doing just that they're
happy to do just that
ok according to the Israeli Security
Agency yahia usually is a Hamas member
arrested on April 29th he told them now
Hamas was instructing its activists to
cut the fence that they want their
activity to be seen quote in the
international media as a popular
uprising and not as a violent action led
by its militants and the Hamas members
are embedded in the general population
for purposes of public relations another
Palestinian terrorist captured by Israel
said that quote Hamas militants in
civilian clothes
encourage children to try to cross the
fence in order to steal IDF equipment in
other words Hamas is using human shields
they're using women they are using
children they are trying to breach the
fence their plan here is that they the
operatives are not gonna breach the
they're gonna let women in children do
it and then they're going to rush
through into Israel and attempt to kill
as many Jews as possible never mind the
Hamas has participated in an ongoing war
with Israel since its election in 2006
they fought Israel 2006 2008 2012 2014
and now they never mind that it must be
the Israelis it must be these it must be
Ivanka Trump this must be a Bank of
trumps fault you know before Ivanka
Trump know this was happening before
about the troubles like Hamas was an
evil terrorist group trying to kill
people it wasn't like they committed
homicide bombings trying to murder
people no no they would never do
anything like that
that would be crazy they're nice people
they're really great by the way here's
some here's some here's some of the
protesters chanting death to America and
death to designers yesterday very nice
people
death to the Zionists yeah just charming
charming folks by the way good indicator
that you're not involved in normal
protesting when you've got your face
covered like that because you don't want
the Israeli troops to know exactly who
you are well the White House did the
right thing here the White House said
the Colossus tube lens here's a rare
shot from the White House doing the
right thing what a difference between
the Trump administration the Obama
administration the Obama administration
constantly looking for an excuse to
blame the only democracy in the Middle
East for defending itself but Raja
not doing that at the White House good
for him well we believe that you know
Hamas is responsible for these for these
tragic deaths that their rather cynical
exploitation of the situation it is what
is what's leading to these deaths and we
want them stopped and that obviously is
true Jared Kushner said the same thing
yesterday at the Jerusalem embassy
everybody was was aware that this is
going on in Gaza and kosher said listen
the people who are provoking violence
are the problem that would be Hamas as
we have seen from the protests of the
last month and even today those
provoking violence are part of the
problem and not part of the solution so
the Trump administration has its head
screwed on straight the media of course
are happy to pare it whatever propaganda
comes down the line and show you some of
that propaganda in just a second because
it really is quite stunning well begin
with NBC's Peter Alexander so Peter
Alexander he asked at the White House
does the u.s. approve of Israel killing
Palestinians at will those are his words
killing Palestinians at will I will show
you in a second that Israel is not
killing Palestinians it will
but it doesn't matter NBC thinks they
are because NBC is is it is an awful
outlet when it comes to its coverage of
Israel here is again Peter Alexander
White House reporter questioning Raja
about Israel's activity so the be clear
is the u.s. not agree with the French
the Israeli authorities should exercise
discretion and just restraint we believe
that Hamas is responsible for what's
going so there's no responsibility on
that on the Israeli authorities kill at
will what I'm saying is that we believe
that Hamas as an organization is engage
in cynical action that's leading to
these deaths kill at will kill it well
so apparently they've been about 60
people killed those statistics are being
put out by Hamas so you never know which
ones are real and which ones are not the
same thing happened during the 2014 Gaza
war when Hamas put out all sorts of
statistics about numbers of civilians
who are killed it turned out the vast
majority of the people who were killed
were actually terrorists or terrorist
associates so here are some of the
pictures of the people who were killed
yesterday in Gaza his from Buren
straight so this reporter in the region
Gaza first martyrdom pictures coming in
1010 killed were members of Hamas as
internal security apparatus why it's so
indiscriminate it's just crazy it's so
indiscriminate 60 people were killed and
10 were members of Hamas because I know
that in America if you shot 60 people
indiscriminately ten would be members of
a terrorist group obviously I mean let's
be real about this if you were to just
randomly mow down a bunch of people
clearly at least one-fifth one-sixth of
them would be actual terrorists maybe
it's not that indiscriminate gang
Islamic Jihad by the way three of them
were members of Islamic Jihad as well
when they're still identifying some of
the other folks their headlines
yesterday about a woman whose baby died
and eight month old baby died after she
was after the area she was in had tear
gas why are you bringing an
eight-month-old baby to an area with
tear gas why in the world would you do
that that's I'm sorry that's under any
circumstance that's evil okay to bring
an eight-month-old baby to a place where
you know tear gas is going to be fired
is the wrong thing - why would you
endanger the life of your child to stand
out there on behalf of Hamas it's just
crazy but look how the media cover this
stuff again Hamas does this for a living
this is their stick it's all for the
cameras it's legitimately all for the
cameras okay so there's there's tape
that is going around today of a
Palestinian doing we see one of these
pretty much every Gaza war a Palestinian
who's a pro
fans on crutches and then the Israelis
start targeting him and he puts down the
crutches and he starts running as fast
as possible
okay amazing he's been cured it's a
miracle thank you Jesus he just did his
crutches he just threw them aside it was
a miracle or it turns out that this sort
of stuff happens routinely because the
Palestinians understand Palestinian
leadership understands the value of a
picture I remember about 10 15 years ago
during anything as the Second Intifada
there was a very famous thing where
there was a march where a Hamas member
was supposed to have died and they were
marching with his body and then the body
fell off of the stretcher and got up and
started walking because the person
wasn't dead at all they just knew the
cameras were on them this sort of stuff
that sort of staging happens routinely
it has been happening for 20 years in
this particular area the media don't
want to cover any of this because the
media want a narrative and media the
media's narrative is this is all Trump's
fault Trump is creating the chaos
ignoring the fact that has been going on
for literally months at this point years
at this point they want to make sure
that Israel is seen as the perpetrator
even though Israel is not the
perpetrator every country has to defend
its border particularly a country has to
defend its border when Hamas is spending
its spare cash and not just to spare
cash all of its cash building terror
Turner's tunnels into Israel to kidnap
Israeli children and Israeli soldiers
and murder as many people as possible
but apparently Israel's the bad guy
here's an MSc MSNBC contributor Eddie
Glaude who yesterday was was very upset
about all the people dead in Gaza while
Donald Trump is doing this and may look
for a deflection it's not necessarily
gonna help the midterms
oh that's important and all of those
babies are dead all of those people are
dead they're dead and and we're talking
about race horses lean the politics I
mean there are a lot of folks who are
dead today okay so why don't we talk
about why all those folks are dead why
don't we talk about why all this folks
are dead instead we're just gonna shout
over and over those people are dead and
then pointed the Jews who again have not
been shooting anyone over there until
the Palestinians decided they were going
to rush the border okay they announced
this in advance this was all planned to
pretend otherwise is a lie and the media
are lying to you the New York Times is
lying to you Fareed Zakaria these are
all these people are lying to you
they're lying to you when they say that
this was spontaneous they're lying to
you when they say this is peaceful it
was not peaceful it was not spontaneous
it was organized by Hamas with the
explicit
I'm attempting to generate these sorts
of headlines in the New York Times the
worst of the bunch okay I have to read
you this this New York Times headline so
the New York Times is now saying that
the United Nations is condemning Israel
who the United Nations oh the vaunted
United Nations the United Nations Human
Rights office issued a series of
statements targeting the Israeli
government and of course the New York
Times immediately parroted them they
tweeted out a picture of a woman hugging
her dead baby again this is the baby
that was killed by tear gas because this
woman decided to obey the commands of
Hamas and go hang out wear tear gas was
being fired genius and the New York
Times tweets out enough is enough
UN Human Rights officials said that
Israel's use of lethal force against
Palestinian demonstrators was
unjustified and could amount to grave
breaches of international law and then
they quote a bunch of people from the UN
they quote Rupert Colville who's the
spokesman for the UN High Commissioner
for Human Rights we condemn the
appalling deadly violence in Gaza
yesterday we're extremely worried about
what may happen later today we're at
similar strains enough is enough now the
New York Times won't tell you who is
actually on the UN Human Rights Council
they won't actually tell you who's on it
it's 15 African states 12 Asian states
five Eastern European states 11 Latin
American and Caribbean states Western
Europe and other states 10 the African
group is chaired by the representative
from Morocco the Asian group is chaired
by the representative from Saudi Arabia
and the Eastern European group is
chaired by the representative from
Azerbaijan so he does a bunch of
countries that love human rights all
three of those places are dictatorships
by the way the UN High Commissioner for
Human Rights
al Hussein is a member of the jordanian
royal family so they won't tell you any
of these things they won't tell you the
Human Rights Council has issued 135
critical resolutions from 2006 to 2016
and 50% of them were directed at Israel
they won't tell you that in the New York
Times they'll just pare it all of the
verbiage of the New York to of the of
the United Nations suggesting that this
was somehow a major statement about
Israeli policy Israel has not farted in
the last 70 years without the UN
condemning them that is just the way the
UN works the UN 1/3 of the UN is staffed
by the Organization of Islamic countries
okay which is like 58 60 countries all
of whom disagree with the existence of
the State of Israel to begin the New
York Times never reports that when they
talk about the UN now the UN is a
vaunted organization I love this from
Fareed Zakaria as well speaking of media
bias Fareed Zakaria trying to
of course that the Jerusalem and he move
is what provoked everything that
happened in Gaza and he says that the
embassy move was a major concession to
Israel is a major concession with
nothing in return the irony of this
statement is beyond words it was a very
non strategic move by which I mean to
say Trump is supposed to be the master
of the art of the deal it's very rare to
make a major concession to one side
without getting something from the other
this has been a prized look there 86
countries that recognizes Israel all
their embassies are in Tel Aviv this is
another this is a very big gift to
Israel you would normally imagine that
if it were part of a larger strategic
plan you would ask the Israelis in
return to do a certain number of things
settlement freezes may you know whatever
it is okay I love this that somehow we
have to the United States is supposed to
use the movements of the embassy to
Jerusalem as leverage against Israel I
don't remember for exact Araya
complaining too much about the Iran deal
in which we handed over a hundred and
fifty billion dollars to the Iranian
government in exchange for nothing and
exchange for zero things they promised
that they would be nice
and remember Fareed Zakaria being quite
that critical but you acknowledge that
Israel's capital is Israel's capital and
the Jerusalem is sovereign Jewish
territory and has been since its
inception and suddenly and then we have
to talk about real trade-offs here we
have to talk about the political
expediency of moving the embassy to
Jerusalem the anti-israel bias and the
media is palpable and we have to examine
why that bias exists in the first place
I think that the bias exists for a
couple of reasons number one if you look
at media coverage of Israel up till 1967
it was very strongly in favor of Israel
that was because the Jews were seen as
the victims until 1967 so media was very
sympathetic to the the plight of the
Jews after the Holocaust and they
believed that Israel should become a
sate and Israel should Israel is a
thriving country that was moving in the
direction of socialism in 1967 Israel
not only defeats its enemies but
destroys its enemies and the six-day war
Israel pushes Egypt all the way back to
Cairo Israel pushes into Jordan Israel
pushes into Syria Israel pushes into
Lebanon it's an amazing military feat
and all of that was incredible and the
the left turns on Israel because now
Israel is seen as the great victimizer
suddenly Israel is a westernized country
that is moving toward the United States
and not toward Russia now it is it is
not a coincidence that the Russian
government the USSR government began
pushing pan-arabism
and alliance with with Russia at the
same time that the West the Western Left
began turning against Israel this is not
a giant coincidence in 1967 the media
turns against Israel and they have never
turned back
and today the argument is that Israel is
the great oppressor in the Middle East
even though Israel is the only liberal
country in the Middle East the only
country where frankly Muslims can live
in democracy in the Middle East there is
no other Muslim democracy in the Middle
East Israel is the best Muslim democracy
in the Middle East and it's a Jewish
country nobody else is voting Israel has
people sitting into Parliament who
believe in the destruction of the State
of Israel that's how much of a democracy
Israel is but Israel is the bad guy hey
Israel is the only place in the Middle
East where gays and lesbians can live in
peace Israel is the only place in the
Middle East where Christians can live in
a relative amount of piece it can Coptic
Christians in Egypt are having a real
rough time right now okay in Israel
you're doing just fine if you're
Christian and yet Israel is the target
and Israel's the target because again
Western civilization according to
members of the hard left is a bad thing
that has created oppression it's created
an intersectional coalition of victim
groups and the Palestinians are among
the victim groups the Jews can no longer
be among the victim groups because now
the Jews of the victimizers and
therefore everything that happens in
Israel doesn't matter if it's
self-defense
doesn't matter if it's a Israel just
protecting its borders everything has to
be Israel's fault and the media are
going to continue to parent these lies
this is why it is incumbent on everyone
to go out and do their own research take
a look at the tape you'll see what
you'll see just a few minutes ago the
Palestinians blew up their own gas Depot
they just blew up their own gas Depot
because they wanted to demonstrate that
Israel was brutal they blew up the
Palestinians who under the guise of
Hamas the Palestinians blew up a border
crossing that was the number one border
crossing for shipping food into Gaza and
then they complain about the lack of
food in Gaza hey all of this is produced
for the cameras and the Western media
make it more likely the Palestinians
will die when they push this stuff it's
just hair honestly it's just terrible it
means more Palestinians will die means
more civilians will die it means that
more Palestinians will believe that
extremism and violence are a way to
convince the Western media to pressure
Israel the media are really complicit in
something quite horrible here it really
is it really is just awful okay so in
just a second I want to talk about the
situation in Seattle where apparently
Seattle has passed what they call their
head tax but first you're gonna have to
go over to Daley wire.com and subscribe
so first let me note that the tickets
that are supposed to be
sale right now for the Ben Shapiro live
events that website is down for the
moment we are fixing it we're on top of
it about subscribers you should
subscribe anyway and you should grab
that promo code because you have from
now all the way until the 17th at 10
o'clock at night to get that exclusive
deal where you can buy tickets to our
live events plus if you are a subscriber
you get to take part in the conversation
where you get to ask questions to the
execrable michael knowles that episode
is today at 5:30 p.m. Eastern 2:30 p.m.
Pacific join me
Michael Knowles and Alicia Kraus on
Tuesday May 15th at 5:30 Eastern 2:30
Pacific for a new episode of the
conversation
it'll be on Facebook and YouTube for
everyone to watch but only daily wire
subscribers can ask questions like these
is Hillary really your cousin I love
that I love that this is true do you
think history will ever be honest
looking back on Obama's legacy yes but
not anytime soon if the White House
offered you a choice to spend the day
with one of the Trump's who would it be
and why I'm going to say that's the safe
answer Oh was it Melania or well what is
your whiskey or bourbon of choice I
prefer a scotch whiskey so my favorite
kind of whiskey but again that's that's
only for breakfast so Evan is asking
where do you get your dresses subscribe
to daily wired.com to ask questions and
join the conversation on may 15th I'll
see you then oh gods if you want to
spend time with that then go over and
check it out and subscribe you can ask
questions to Michael moles also can be
part of our mailbag which is happening
on Friday but the biggest thing of
course is that if you subscribe right
now then you get early access to our
events in Dallas and Phoenix we're going
to be adding new events to the calendar
as well and subscribers are gonna have
access to those events early too that's
one of the magical benefits of becoming
a subscriber the annual subscription is
$99 a year not $9.99 a month you get
this as well the leftist Cheers hot or
cold tumblr it is fantastic if you just
want to listen later iTunes SoundCloud
YouTube subscribe leave us a review we
always have great stuff coming out we
are the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
all righty so meanwhile Seattle has
decided that a great job a great a great
idea would be to put a head tax on the
major the on the biggest company in
their City so I used to do a radio show
in Seattle specifically for a Katie th
in Seattle which is also a station that
carries the show and and Katie th but
one of the things that we did is we do
debate with Chama San Juan Chama San
Juan is a City Councilwoman for CIO
she's an open socialist she's a person
who actually said that the Boeing plant
should be taken over okay and the Boeing
plan should make civilian airliners you
take everything that was being made for
the military and convert it to civilian
airliners I believe is what she said
about Boeing she is a kind of crazy
person I did a debate with her about
minimum wage she was the leader of the
$15 minimum wage campaign she was also
the leader of this concept she wanted a
head tax on Amazon the head tax on
Amazon would establish a tax have two
hundred seventy five dollars per
employee per year on companies with more
than 20 million dollars in annual
revenue in the city which means
basically Starbucks and amazon.com I
mean those those are the only two
companies that make more than twenty
million dollars in in Seattle at least
they're very few the tax passed on
Monday it's supposed to raise 50 million
dollars annually to fight the
homelessness crisis under the amended
tax Amazon will be on the hook for about
eleven million dollars annually rather
than the twenty million in the original
proposal would have levied here with
shamisen wants trying to push the head
tax we're talking about taxing either
the five or the ten person or somewhere
in that range of the largest businesses
in Seattle so these are not your
mom-and-pop stores your local coffee
shops immigrant owned stores we're
talking about the Amazons the Facebook's
the Macy's the Nordstrom's it the really
top tier corporations that are making
historic profits and making profits for
their billionaire shareholders so we're
saying if you take a small amount of
those corporations profits and you raise
about 150 million dollars every year you
could build up to 750 permanently
affordable units we know the market has
not solved the problem we need to do
something but I'm absolutely opposed to
small businesses paying any tax
okay so small businesses shouldn't pay
taxes according to Shama so on but all
of the large businesses should pay all
the taxes Microsoft by the way of course
is also located in Seattle okay so here
is the problem the idea here is that all
this money's going to be tossed into
affordable housing and I know something
Seattle's problem with the homeless has
nothing to do with the fact that Amazon
is located in Seattle so yes there are
more people who are working in Seattle
this means that there is more upward
pressure on the prices for rent and for
home owning in Seattle but you know what
that would normally generate a lot of
building would it not right it would
normally generate a lot of developers
building things you know like building
new units they can take advantage of the
booming economy in Seattle and the fact
that Seattle is now a population magnet
one of the few population magnets in a
leftist state wouldn't that be wouldn't
that be logical well there's one problem
the City Council has also barred
developers from building new stuff so
that means there are no new units and so
the rents are going up it turns out that
when there is high demand and low supply
the prices are high also Seattle in an
attempt to not get rid of those
regulations and attempt to avoid those
regulations Seattle has allowed tent
cities to crop up all around the city
just as in San Francisco if you walk
around Seattle now you will see
ginormous tent cities located on under
freeway underpasses
on there there's a situation a few years
back where a guy who was homeless fell
off a freeway overpass okay onto the
freeway all of this stuff has been
happening because Seattle has stupid
regulations with regard to housing and
they also have regulations with regard
to affordable housing that don't
actually put restrictions on the people
who can come into the affordable housing
so they have something called the drunk
dorms in Seattle where people go there
and they're still using drugs they're
still drunk they wrecked the place and
then they leave and Seattle has created
these enormous tent cities they've
changed regulations in Seattle so that
they can allow these ten cities to crop
up in residential areas and of course
people who live in residential areas
aren't super happy about the idea of
having a tent city full of homeless
people where disease can easily spread
in areas where they live but the Seattle
City Council because they're liberal
because they're so kind-hearted they've
decided it's not important to allow
developers to build more units no not
that instead we are going to tax the
hell out of Amazon now it's amazing is
that you see tech workers actually
protesting this because they understand
that it's quite possible that if these
taxes continue to rise companies like
Amazon companies like Microsoft if they
have to open a new outlet if they have
to open a new building they're not gonna
do it in Seattle they're gonna move out
they're gonna find someplace else that's
not going to tax them $275 an employee
so this was it this is really funny
they're a bunch of City Council members
speaking about the head tax and a bunch
of tech workers were out there actually
yelling at them no head tax
I mean look at these guys blue-collar
guys we're in actual hard hats okay and
that is not a bunch of stage nonsense
these are a bunch of people who
understand that these businesses are
going to locate elsewhere it's always
amazing that there's so many folks on
the Left who are unwilling to see the
unintended consequences of their of
their economic actions they say listen
we have to be so sympathetic to the
homeless we have to let them sleep on
the streets we do we have to let them
sleep on it so what happened homeless
people from other places come and sleep
on the streets of Seattle and then the
homeless population grows in you know
what we have to be sympathetic what we
really should do is we should allow them
to bring tents which will have them
build tents well build tents and then
we'll bring resources to bear to help
them out and what happens the population
swells and I have thousands of people on
the streets of Seattle living in tents
they say you know what probably all
these people are here not because
there's a severe mental illness issue
with a lot of folks who are homeless
not that there's severe drug issue with
a lot of folks that are homeless they're
here because they could they used to
work at Amazon another unemployed and
they can't get a house it must be the
affordable housing crisis now we don't
want to let people build new
developments because that would just
spoil our water line I mean now that
would support that would spoil the
skyline of Seattle if we were to have
new developments being built we can't do
that we certainly can't do that but what
we can do is we can take the businesses
that we do have and we can really tax
them to build affordable housing so they
build more affordable housing and what
happens a bunch more homeless people
show up to take advantage of the
affordable housing and the businesses
leave because now the taxes are higher
this is how you clean out nice major
cities you take a major city that is
booming economically you slap a bunch of
crappy left policy on top of it and
guess what happens people leave
businesses take off in the state of
California they've been seeing this for
years when you raise taxes businesses
leave when you create new regulations
businesses leave then listen the climate
in Seattle is nice like at least eight
days a year but that doesn't mean that
these companies are gonna stay there for
those eight days a year they will move
out just because they started in Seattle
doesn't mean they aren't going to
gradually move out in and you're seeing
that Boeing for example which is located
in the Seattle Tacoma area
Boeing has started building plants all
over the country in other places where
they are not going to be cracked down on
by local governments this is why you
should not elect socialists your local
government city of Seattle and small
businesses is the ideas that is going to
benefit small businesses having all the
consumers
all the people who work in Amazon buy
from small businesses having all those
consumers leave is not going to help the
small businesses who are located in
Seattle but again all that matters is
the intention and the people in Seattle
city government they feel so good about
themselves they feel so nice about
themselves
the reason I talk about Seattle is
because the left likes to use these sort
of economic policies writ large there
are always stupid they're always
counterproductive and that's exactly
what's gonna happen here it's gonna be
stupid and it's gonna be
counterproductive okay meanwhile
President Trump is very very angry about
leaking so as we discussed yesterday
there's serious problem inside the White
House with people leaking to media
outlets outside the White House and part
of that is because the media are so on
top of everything that's happening in
this White House they love the rumors
they love the chaos it is their favorite
narrative but over the past couple of
days there was a leak that really hurt
the administration we're a relatively
mid-level staffer said in a meeting and
it was Sadler she she said in a meeting
that we they didn't have to worry about
John McCain's bones you know how small
the CIA nominee because McCain was gonna
die soon anyway they should just come
out and finish the story they should
just said listen sorry never should have
said it it was it was a bad joke made a
made in a bad moment instead they didn't
and so this story continues now into day
seven which is really a waste of time
but Donald Trump has tweeted out quote
the so-called leaks coming out of the
White House on a massive
over-exaggeration put out by the fake
news media in order to make us look as
bad as possible with that being said
leakers are traitors and cowards and we
will find out who they are well part of
the problem for President Trump here is
that when it comes to staffing of his
administration the chaos in the
administration does start from the top
there's a lot of backbiting during the
campaign a lot of backbiting people in
the administration do not like each
other there are a lot of people in the
administration who are odds with one
another and they know that there's
always an eager ear on the other end of
the phone one thing that you can say
about george w bush and something else
that you can say about barack obama
within their teams they inspired a
certain amount of unity and cohesiveness
have you talked to Dana Perino who
worked in the bush White House everybody
was basically on the same page they
understood the george w bush was the
boss and they understood that they were
not going to be able to turn against
each other and leaked to the press all
that often without Bush stepping in and
doing something about it the problem for
President Trump is the president Trump
actually likes the cast he's always
liked the governance by cast he sort of
sees his administration the same way the
Joker sees staffing up his his gang
right
Donald Trump's the kind of guy president
Trump's the kinda guy who likes to break
a pool cue in half and and toss it in
front of three guys and then say okay
that I've room for one of you and that
sort of had from has always operated
he's done this with a lot of his
staffers for a very long time but that's
going to do is generate an incentive for
people who are working under President
Trump to leak bad stuff about other
staffers and try and get them out stood
on the basis of that now what President
Trump probably should do is you should
take everybody in that room who is not a
vital employee and fire them you should
probably fire everyone in that room
because apparently well many people in
the room I've talked to some people who
are in that room apparently not a lot of
people in that room so that means they
could probably fire people and get away
with it okay and not only that you
probably should fire people because you
need to send the message to your own
administration that leaks will not be
tolerated and that this then this sort
of this sort of attempt to take down the
administration from the inside will not
be tolerated either now do I think that
these are deep state holdovers no I
think what this really is is a bunch of
people who don't like each other and
they see a warm ear in the media and
they are more than happy to exploit that
warm ear in the media so again I think
that President Trump should do a better
job of staffing his administration and
and he should do a better job of
cracking down on leakers especially the
ones who are working for the executive
branch you can't really control what's
happening over the FBI or the CIA too
much but he can't control what is
happening inside the White House for
sure now meanwhile the Khan Film
Festival is going on this is of course
the place where everybody talks about
movies that no one will ever see and one
of the big movies that's about to come
out is a movie from Spike Lee who has
not made a good movie since do the right
thing it's been quite a while since
Spike Lee made anything relevant well
he's made a new movie it's called black
KKK Klansmen sure to be a massive headed
theaters and apparently the film is
about race relations from the 1970s to
present and Spike Lee says the film was
quote on the right side of history a
phrase that I absolutely despise there
is no right side of history there is
just right and wrong history doesn't
have a side it's a bunch of stuff that
happened
Spike Lee says about President Trump
that mf'er was given a chance to say we
are about love and not hate and that
mf'er did not denounce the M the M
effing klan the alt-right
and those Nazi MF errs it was a defining
moment he could have said that to the
world that we were better than that
black click that KKK Klansmen is built
is based on an incredible true story of
black police detective ron Stallworth
who infiltrated the KKK in the
and variety is called the film as much a
compelling black empowerment story as it
is an electrifying commentary on the
problems of african-american
representation across more than a
century of cinema and this is being
hailed as a great movie maybe it is
maybe it's really good we will find out
in in very short order suffice it to say
Hollywood is not warming to President
Trump in any serious way
Spike Lee actually wanted to make things
better perhaps you should reach out to
President Trump listen I think criticism
is warranted about a lot of the things
that President Trump has said but I
think at this point your best move is to
reach out to President Trump he clearly
wants to reach out to people of on all
sides at the very least you could be
reaching out in exchange okay time for
some things I like and then a thing that
I hate so today's thing that I like so
I'm excited about this is really cool so
my dad back in the early 90s has like
eight years old he wrote a musical about
the Scarlet Pimpernel The Scarlet
Pimpernel is of course a very famous
novel classic novel about a British a
British guy who tries to go to
revolutionary France during the French
Revolution and spirit away aristocrats
to save them from the guillotine there's
a very bad musical version made by Frank
Wildhorn it is not good it was panned by
the New York Times for the reason it's
garbage my dad wrote a musical version
the music and lyrics for the Scarlet
Pimpernel the book was by a guy named
Dave Waller who's a good friend my
father's eye and the musical is really
first-rate we put it up on YouTube and
you can listen to the entire thing the
libretto is also available there you can
click on a link it will take you to the
full-text so you can see what everybody
is saying and it really is a lot of fun
here is what it sounds like this is the
beginning of the scarlet pimpernel this
is the scene in the in the Revolutionary
square where where aristocrats are being
beheaded and the population of course is
very excited about all of this
[Music]
[Applause]
so if you like Lemus okay then this is I
think better than lame is the music is
is more set to the time but it's it's
really good the lyrics are really clever
and you can check out the whole thing
over at YouTube and read the entire
libretto there I remember when my dad
was making this it was really really
cool it went to a festival in New York
and then the wilds word version came out
at the same time as this and the wild
herd and version had a lot of money
behind it but it is it's a really really
good piece of work it's an amazing piece
of work actually so go check it out the
scarlet pimpernel by my father and so
you can check it out at YouTube and give
it a listen
okay time for a quick thing that I hate
okay so the thing that I hate today
stormy the annuals has been hailed as a
heroine she's a she's a female
empowerment legend stormy Daniels she's
just a wonderful wonderful person who is
standing up to the predations of evil
evil men well it turns out that she has
some problems of her own
so according to Tasha rain who is
another porn star she tweeted out quote
I was inappropriately groped in sexually
harassed by one of the men on your crew
November 15th right before my B G scene
which you were then made aware of that
day you continued to allow him to stay
on the set with no repercussions
I never questioned your directorial
skills so she says that she can't she
couldn't believe that store McDaniels
was talking about how she was always so
good for women and you should stand up
for yourself and you should report it so
he was very upsetting to see her speak
there like that and I think but I know
the real you I was there I saw what you
did
she said it's tricky because I don't
even like stormy I don't like her at all
she says I was sexually assaulted by one
of her crew members he grew up then
grabbed me from behind I spoke up
immediately because I was in the moment
now I'm so proud of myself she was the
director that day I went straight to her
and straight to the man that did it had
a conversation about I wants the owner
of wicked pictures I did all the right
things and she did not handle the
situation appropriately respect
we are professionally so it's a little
bit outrageous when I hear her say
things about how she is standing up for
women and wants to be a voice for other
women to be able to come for when I was
assaulted on her set and she didn't give
me any care attention and didn't even
send that man home
apparently this happened November 15th
of last year okay so this is pretty
recent
she said I'd always looked up to stormy
I'd shot for her before ran her into her
conventions we even traveled once to
Seattle at the beginning of my career
when I believe they were considering me
for a contract oral position at wicked I
know her so I was stoked and she had
some dialogue and then she she says that
Daniels was basically making fun of the
me2 movement in so many words talking to
the crew you know I could be seen as
Harvey Weinstein because I'm flirtatious
with my crew members and I can be
inappropriate and apparently rein was
uncomfortable but she let it go so all
of this suggests that stormy Daniels may
not in fact be the innocent decent human
being that we all thought she was I
can't believe it I am so shocked I am so
shot again this is any of this justify
president Trump's behavior no but before
the media start slapping slapping a
crown on this lady slapping a head
redundant nun's habit on this woman and
declaring that she's a saint
they might want to take a look at her
history and Tasha rein speaking up and
saying well yes stormy Daniels not such
a great person
okay so we'll be back here tomorrow with
all the latest I'm sure that there will
be lots more horrible reports from the
media about what's going on in Israel
will have to debunk all of them and
we'll be up we will be back there then I
am Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Alexander Oh audio is mixed by
Mike Carmina hair and makeup is by
Joshua Oliveira the Ben Shapiro show is
a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright floor publishing